thank you so much for joining us we're
happy that you're on with us senior
writer greg bishop here with si
thank you so much for having me it's my
pleasure can you walk us through just
incredibly
how arduous this has to have been for
you leading up until the super bowl and
you're embedded with both teams and you
don't know who's going to win and
suddenly there's a winner there's a
champion and now you've got to go
deadline how do you do it
well i can start by saying it's always
my favorite and least favorite story of
the year that makes sense you know
basically we have to be ready either way
i like to be ready for whoever plays
well in the game i want to be able to
sort of tell the story of their season
tell the story of their individual
background and how they arrive there and
then ideally be able to stitch it all
together
that generally means in the neighborhood
of a hundred interviews or so
i do it usually with another writer this
year i did it with uh connor orr it's
really an amazing couple weeks
and uh you know then we get ready for
any scenario that might happen so that's
aaron donald that's von miller that's
matthew stafford that's les sneed that's
sean mcvay
and in this instance it was kind of rare
they they all factored so prominently
into the wind that we ended up riding a
ton i usually start writing about
3am eastern and i usually file by 8 am
and so
those are the most frenetic you know
hours of my existence for every year
and
at the end i have no idea whether the
story's good or not but uh usually we
finish which is a good thing
how do you get so in depth how do you
write when you weren't in these
particular situations like for instance
the evening of january 30th you write
about the staffords and the whitworths
in cabo they just happen to be there at
the same time
you write like you're there
how do you do that
yeah i think it's a product of speaking
to as many people who were there as
possible you know i'm really looking for
you know direct eyewitnesses for lack of
a better term and
you know when writing about the rams
trip to cabo it starts out by talking to
some of the wives who were in attendance
whether it was melissa whitworth or sean
mcrae's girlfriend veronica
um then it's like i find out from them
that clint bowling is the one that
connected whitworth and stafford that
this was all set in motion by of all
people a former bengal who had played
with matthew in college and with andrew
in the pros
and then i take that information and i
said i need to talk to bowling so i get
him on the phone make sure that he
confirms it add additional detail
and then the other interviews begin to
roll in you know so then you talk to
matthew stafford you talk to sean mcvay
and you're getting their impressions of
the night
and then they have these faith time
calls you know after they've decided
that that the move is going to be made
they've made the trade for matthew
stafford and they're calling cooper cup
they're calling aaron donald
they're calling the executives who
helped shape the deal back in los
angeles and so you want the other side
of those phone conversations as well
so when i end up writing a section on
cabo and the trip that changed this nfl
season
i have it from 15 to 20 different
vantage points and it's the level of
detail those people provide that
hopefully makes the story you know kind
of feel that way and you mentioned that
you had
thousands of words on eric weddle and
you have to whittle it down to a
paragraph how do you decide what's
important how do you decide what's going
to stay on the in the computer or on the
floor
yeah that's always the hardest part you
know i think when i dropped everything i
had pre-written whether it was for
stories that ran online or for stuff i
called pre-writing you know just sort of
to have
into the file with that and interviews
and research at about midnight
last sunday i had about 77 000 words it
ended up running about 8500
and
that that was a task i probably should
not have given myself it was very very
difficult to cut it down the first
50 000 are pretty easy the next 10 000
or
get you close and then we're agonizing
every over every single word and so i'm
weighing things like what can i use
later
you know who would be a good story down
the road who might make for a good
magazine story in our next issue because
we can't publish the super bowl game
story in the issue because of the lag
time between clothes and prints but we
do do a special commemorative issue
that's just about the rams
so i may have something on one of the
players in the next issue i'm i'm
looking at how do these things relate to
each other i'm trying to consider the
time of the people that want to read
this thing and how far they're going to
make it in the story
and then you know you just make a lot of
painful cuts cuts that still hurt you
know four days later stuff i wish was in
the world but just didn't quite fit
yeah like what i'd love to know what
that cut is that you're wishing that you
could have included in the piece for s.i
you know i ended up writing 4 300 words
on matthew stafford and he was a big
part of the game but because i wanted to
fit in
von miller telling sean mcvay come get
me at a nightclub in 2018 and i wanted
to fit in
widow playing pickup basketball games to
try to get his pro athlete fix and i
wanted to fit in beckham insisting on
number three and having to negotiate
with cam acres
in order to come over
you know that i ended up using maybe a
thousand words of stafford when i would
have liked to have used more you know
there was a one story that i really
loved
where he's at dinner with a couple lions
teammates and he doesn't know what
american express points are and they're
all kind of laughing at just how normal
he is you know this is not a guy
that seems like a star quarterback he
doesn't even know
that he has american express points and
they have him look it up on his app how
many he has and it turns out he has 2
million
youtube because that's like not
something that he had thought through
and i had all these cool stories about
just how normal matthew stafford is
whether he's wearing a hoodie to nobu or
you know um taking his linemen you know
on different trips and you know how he
would go on vacation every
year when the super bowl happened
because he was never playing in it and
you know i i imagine you'll see a
matthew stafford you know focus story
and sports illustrated at some point and
not too long for me from now
greg bishop senior writer from sports
illustrated here on the rich eisen show
susie schuster in for rich eisen you
mentioned in the piece how you call him
or maybe you say that others call him a
borderline genius with something close
to a photographic memory and an immature
mathematician
give me some evidence of him as an
amateur mathematician or a borderline
genius please
yeah it's really interesting right
because i think when i think of matthew
stafford i think howitzer arm you know
this the guy that they say made 82 yard
throws in practice you know i talked to
calvin johnson for the story and he says
matthew stafford throw the ball so hard
that
essentially my fingers are messed up but
i think because he throws the ball so
well and because he's known for this
sort of golden arm
that we've consistently kind of
overlooked his thought process
and his friends say that he actually
would be like a perennial winner on
jeopardy i thought that part really
stood out to me you know this is a guy
that could go on that show
and win you know he they say they
actually hate watching it with him
because he's the kind of person that
answers every question immediately when
he comes out and
you know one of his friends was saying
to me if you ask him to say what's the
square root of 69 times 3 divided by 4
that if you gave him 10 seconds he could
come up with the answer
and that's not how i'd ever thought of
matthew stafford but if you think a
little deeper on it it makes total sense
you know sean mcvay is
known as the savant type really good
with numbers incredible memory cooper
cup described exactly the same way
and you look at one thing that flipped
the ram season that made something like
this possible to me it is those three
guys
their sort of deep nerdy knowledge of
football
and how they process offensive offensive
schemes and i think what you saw the
season was they got away from them in
november didn't win a game that month
and then they adjusted and they adjusted
while they lost robert woods while they
added odell beckham jr
and that those kind of things are what
what i think are what i'm looking for in
the story like how does how does how do
things in their background relate to
what happened in their season and these
guys met every tuesday
and they talked offensive football at a
level that like made it seem like french
and
because they had those meetings because
they were able to adjust and because
they think through things in that way
i think it's a big reason they were able
to do just enough in that game to score
when it looked like they were out of
answers and to me that that's kind of
the arc involved and that's that's what
i'm really looking for
greg bishop senior writer from si here
on the rich eisen show the name of his
story is uh how the rams got away found
one another and then found a way what
was the biggest surprise to you or who
was the biggest surprise to you as you
wrote this story
you know probably von miller you know
one of the things that i love about this
story is that it's um so circular in
nature you know in in 2016 when the
broncos won i wrote on a golf cart with
vaughn
you know throughout the stadium as he
did interviews i ended up following him
the whole next summer while he took over
70 flights and flew like 140 000 miles
and competed with dancing with the stars
but you kind of move on right and move
on into
other stories other orbits and you know
bonn and i didn't exactly stay in touch
but
he remembered all of that and what was
really cool is he had been able to kind
of trace where he was then to now and so
he told me that
story about running into cliff kingsbury
in the nightclub sean mcday's there they
have a bunch of shots he says come get
me
he told me he would pull over on his way
to gaines in denver when things were bad
and have to throw up because he was so
anxious
he talked about meeting trevor moad you
know an amazing mental coach who passed
last fall
from brain cancer and how trevor changed
his life introduced him to kobe bryant
kobe bryant ends up um you know
obviously dying in the helicopter crash
vaughn moved down the street from where
the crash happened when he gets traded
he reunites with odell beckham jr who's
one of his best friends
mcvay remembers their conversation it
was it was just so poetic and how
circular it was that it really
kind of floored me that not only had he
grown but he could see the aims of the
story as they related to his life and
having a kid and playing for demarius
thomas and
i just thought he really opened a vein
the last couple weeks and i was really
really grateful for it
before we let you go i was also struck
by how you got inside les needs mind and
especially him getting up early to go
swim in the ocean and
starting the day in that seneca away the
roman philosopher
what was the what's your lasting
impression of les and how he was so
successful at putting this team together
yeah i just loved everything about our
interactions and i always tell my
colleagues we got to do everything we
can every interaction to get one
paragraph and so this year with less
that meant not only did we jog six miles
up and down the beach you know past
peter bronson's house past
steven spielberg's house and the
security guards out front
but we also uh took a plunge into the
pacific ocean
and it was cold and it was fun and it
honestly felt a little bit rejuvenating
but
to me the plunge was left it wasn't
uh willy-nilly it was planned it's
something he's been doing
you know every morning this year to sort
of get in touch with his stoic roots and
i just think that he is a
deep deep thinker i think there's a
danger sometimes in people who look at
him and see
a gambler who plays blackjack with pro
football players and who doesn't have a
real plan involved like like or hate the
way that they operate
i think les is very deliberate and i
think he comes from being smart i think
it comes from
understanding that you know this is the
way he wants to do it and i wrote about
a meeting he had with pete with peter
thiel the billionaire
in which you know teal's emphasis to him
was that with one thing that makes him
successful one tenet of his philosophy
is what do i know that nobody else knows
and i think lesney believes that draft
picks particularly in higher rounds
particularly because they are hit and
miss or overvalued and
to me what he's doing is taking
calculated plunges and
you know to be able to spend time with
him and the way that he
allowed me to i think allows me to sort
of see how all these parts of his life
connect whether it's books on stoicism
meeting with ryan holiday
or you know pulling a full seneca and
jumping into the ocean every morning
it's not like he has that part of his
life and in the football part to me they
are connected they speak to a philosophy
that's very clearly defined
and you know all you need at that point
is time with him to sort of really draw
the connections out and that's another
one that i was really grateful for
even even the way you mentioned casually
in his notebook he wrote who is this guy
cooper cup you really
greg i can't tell you enough how much i
enjoyed it you really take us there in
the moment you really made us feel like
you were along for the ride you really
made us feel like we were intimately
involved in this build up
and i can't thank you enough it's just
spectacular
you're far too kind dude i need to have
you be my new agent so thank you very
much for the kind words means a lot i'm
available and there are many people
who'd probably say i'm not too kind so
i'll take it with you but how the rams
got away found one another and then
found a way greg just spectacularly
written thanks again for your time hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here